several Californians are working to
protect a native species critical to our
food chain today marks the start of
national pollinator week Charlie all
right
highs are credit pollinators but some
Fridays I know you're ready always ready
for butterflies
some varieties are disappearing most
recognizable victim is of course the
monarch butterfly efforts are underway
to bring the colorful creatures back
from the brink of extinction John
Blackstone shows us how one man is
helping a native species re-emerge in
San Francisco as an aquatic biologist
Tim Wong is responsible for all kinds of
water loving wildlife at the California
Academy of Sciences in San Francisco
they're a stick insect and actually one
of the largest insects in the world but
it's another kind of insect that really
sets his heart aflutter native
butterflies were kind of always a part
of my life growing up one particular
species caught your eye yeah and it's
just such a beautiful iridescent blue
tropical looking butterfly the
California pipevine Swallowtail is
native to Northern California but in the
last century as San Francisco grew
nearly all of its habitat was lost to
urban development gone was the one plant
it needs to complete its life cycle the
pipevine this is all native vegetation
it is yeah I'm the living roof at the
Academy of Sciences Wong began his
one-man mission to grow more pipevine
and in turn bring back the pipevine
Swallowtail so what we're looking at
here is a buffet for the caterpillars
right it is yeah at San Francisco's
Botanical Gardens where Wong created a
habitat ideal for the Swallowtail she's
looking for the perfect spot to lay her
eggs they're actually really picky he's
become known as the butterfly whisperer
you can think like a butterfly I can
kind of think like a butterfly and I
almost know what they're looking for it
what butterflies of all kinds are
looking for is the right habitat that is
becoming increasingly difficult for
nearly every species as their natural
environments are disappearing the single
greatest cause of extinction is the loss
of habitat bill tooms organization eco
life is
working to protect the forests in Mexico
where the most studied butterfly the
monarch spends the winter in the last 20
years the population of monarchs has
dropped by more than 80 percent as its
habitat has disappeared that's raising
concerns because butterflies like bees
contribute to the food chain playing a
critical role in the plant fertilization
process butterflies are important
because they're a pollinator and
pollinators account for one out of every
three bites of food we take without them
we will die tun is part of a campaign
spearheaded by the US Fish and Wildlife
Service encouraging communities to
replant native species creating
butterfly gardens to help them survive
in San Francisco retired firefighter
Mike Belcher has done just that it's
kind of like ranching we raise cattle
you grow alfalfa
so I grow plants for butterflies
Belcher's butterfly oasis includes all
kinds of flowering plants and a huge
pipevine for that elusive San Francisco
butterfly I planted it here 17 years ago
with the hope that someday maybe the
pipevine Swallowtail would find it and
breed here and this year they did for
the first time laying eggs on his pipe
vine the line I use is if you plant it
they will come eventually eventually
eventually you just got to wait good to
have them back in San Francisco that's
fantastic Belcher figures much of the
credit goes to Tim Wong's work and it's
finally paying off Long's plants now
have a bumper crop of AIDS and they're
laid in clusters because when the
caterpillars hatch they forage as a
group and feed like a little caterpillar
army the return of the pipevine
Swallowtail is encouraging but the
monarchs face a long and challenging
journey back from the brink both need a
lot of help from their friends for CBS
this morning John Blackstone San
Francisco be kind to your pollinators
they are really important to the food
chain who knew that it was national
pollinator week
now very very good to know Charlie knew
Charlie had it marked on the calendar
good